on this the 527th day of 15 days to slow
the spread the leader of the formerly
free world dr fauci is finally offering
guidance on when we will finally have
slowed the spread and flattened the
curve and we'll be able to get back to
normal life i've got the answer for you
just one more year
i do want to ask you something about you
that you said to npr today you said if
the majority of americans get vaccinated
quote we could start to really get some
good control over this as we get back
into the fall of 2022
a year from now is that the best case
scenario and what does control look like
no you know i
you know
anderson i have to apologize when i
listen to the tape i meant to say the
spring of 2022 so i didn't miss speak
and in the conversation with mary louise
kelly she was saying when do i think
we're going to start to get some control
i said if we can get through
this winter and get really the majority
overwhelming majority of the 90 million
people who have not been vaccinated
vaccinated i hope we could start to get
some good control in the spring of 2022.
i didn't mean the fall i misspoke
oh his bad his bed it's not going to be
a full year it's just going to be a
little more than half a year and boy is
that a relief you see because i i
thought it would be a year before we
could get back to normal instead it's
just going to be 207 more days for a
total of 734
days to slow the spread which is just
shy of 50 times as long as they
initially told us that it would be
before they changed that prediction a
bunch of times but i bet they're telling
the truth this time right i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from lewis fishman who
says
we haven't lost any equipment
there it is it's right there where we
abandoned it in afghanistan
that's true that's true you can't this
was actually the point i made in my
column on afghanistan you can't lose a
war
that you never set goals
to win
you can't you can't lose if you
if you set out to lose in the first
place right then you sort of win when
you lose
we all lose when big tech companies spy
on our data which is why i would
strongly recommend expressvpn i do not
go online without a vpn okay what is a
vpn a vpn is a simple
app for your computer or smartphone that
encrypts all your network data and
tunnels it through this secure server so
that your isp your internet service
provider cannot see any of your activity
when i go online i go online with
expressvpn the best out there that's
just what i do if the nsa spying on
turkey carlson
didn't convince you of this then i don't
know what will okay
so much of our lives now are on the
internet people are looking at what
you're doing they're trying to get your
data okay i recommend expressvpn as the
best way to hide your online activity
from your isp you just download the app
tap one button on your device and you're
protected
i know a lot of people don't think about
this
wake up every we are living in the age
of surveillance capitalism everyone is
trying to get your data stop handing
over your personal data to the isps
protect yourself with the people that i
trust e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael to get three extra months for
free go on over expressvpn.com slash
michael right now to learn more
how much
longer
is dr fauci going to be able to keep up
this charade
the answer is for as long as people
believe him and i'm obviously if you're
listening to this show
you probably
do not believe dr fauci very much
because he has lied because he has been
wrong because he is misled on many
occasions for over a year now
but just that number how do people get
over that number
15 days to slow the spread oh no another
month oh another two months oh another
one more season oh one more
just one more just one more just one
more it's going to be
over two years
by the time this is all done
and probably more than that i don't know
why we would believe that it'll only be
two years now
they have radically extended the
timeline again and again you see fauci
he doesn't want to
he doesn't he respects people's freedom
but
the other thing that you just mentioned
now
is they're going to give a lot of
incentive and backing for a lot of
institutions and organizations and
places of employment to mandate and that
could be colleges university the
military
organizations that employ a lot of
people some of the big corporations are
going to say if you want to work for us
in person you've got to be there and get
vaccinated and i think that's a good
thing i know i respect people's freedom
but when you're talking about a public
health crisis that we've been going
through now for well over a year and a
half the time has come enough is enough
we've just got to get people vaccinated
enough is enough you peasants i respect
your freedom but
when politicians
use the word but
almost always they do so to negate
whatever they have just said
i was look listen here you
i respect your freedom but
i don't
i gotcha dectafochi
this
jerk this jerk
why he is permitted
to pontificate after being wrong on so
many things and admitting to lying about
other like the masks right he said well
the reason i said that the the masks
don't work is because i wanted to save
masks for the people in the hospitals so
you say it's not i thought there would
be a shortage right he's not saying he
said the masks wouldn't work because he
thought the masks wouldn't work he's
saying i said the masks wouldn't work
because i wanted to save them for people
who i would prefer to have have them
a lot of people are pointing this out i
mean i've mentioned this before how he
has no credibility but in as a political
matter this is
actually probably a strength for fouchy
if fouchy just stuck by his story
for the entirety of the lockdowns then
it would be very easy to prove that he
got things wrong but that's not what
fouchy does that's not how he operates
that's not how he's operated since the
beginning of his career going all the
way back to aids
fauci holds virtually every side of
every issue
at some point
so that
he always will have gotten something
right he'll have gotten everything else
wrong but he'll have always gotten
something right if he's constantly
changing then you can't just look to the
science you can't just look to the data
you can't just look to some principle
you just look to his whims his caprice
that's that's the i mean this is what
demagogues do
they
take away your attention from
some objective truth or some principle
and they just put it in
their own will and fouchy's will is
going to extend this for now
at least another what seven eight months
probably more than that
so
of course
people are making comparisons to tyrants
and yes people are comparing fauchi to
hitler and to nazis now i i don't
generally make nazi comparisons because
i i find that people only make those
comparisons because they don't really
know anything else about history so
they'll say when you know trump is
hitler it's because they don't they
don't know anything about any historical
event other than
world war ii and even that they probably
don't know very much about but they've
at least heard the name hitler's they
say you're like hitler but there are
other historical events so i generally
don't make the nazi comparisons
but dr fauci is very upset because
people are comparing him to 20th century
tyrants how do you feel when you hear
republican state lawmakers in maine and
elsewhere we played a clip a moment ago
comparing public health officials
scientists such as yourself doctors
trying to get americans vaccinated
to nazis to joseph mengele talking about
neurum nuremberg trials and more
i think it's completely crazy
i mean anybody who has any common sense
and looks at that
and sees what they are doing
the same people that are saying
it's being like a nazi to try and get
somebody to do an intervention that
would save their life
at the same time that they're jumping
around grabbing ivormectum and getting
toxicity from it it's just bizarre maybe
totally bizarre totally bizarre it's so
irresponsible to compare anyone to a
nazi especially after we just had
president hitler trump
right especially after george w hitler
that we had before him
i i just don't want to hear it i don't
want to hear any complaint about fauci
being called hitler or a nazi or mengele
or whatever
the left almost exclusively compares the
republicans to nazis they they did it
obviously for the entirety of trump
people forget now they did it for the
entirety of the george w bush
administration they did it to reagan so
i just don't want to hear it sorry i
don't care i don't care about fauci's
feelings i don't care about his
expertise i don't care about his
political power that he's maintained for
what
five decades now or something four
decades he
is a jerk
he's a jerk no one should believe him no
one should follow his advice he should
be fired but he probably won't be he
probably won't be because these guys
have power and they're going to wield it
bill de blasio in new york has summed
this up he summed up the left's approach
to you
your society your rights and your way of
life he was asked about
the mandates
so you know you'll remember
when the vaccine first came out de
blasio was just offering all these
goodies to people to get it he offered
them cheeseburgers he said if you go he
was eating the cheeseburger
live in person it was disgusting it was
there's
good cheeseburger now stick yourself
with the experimental drug i mean i'll
give you cheeseburger my french fries my
my was so gross uh so that was the that
was the carrot then he's offering the
stick which is you're gonna be punished
if you don't get it because there's a
mandate this is this is not just his
theory on kovid this is his theory on
human nature
look human beings do well when they have
carrot and stick so
a mandate helps people to realize it's
time fda final approval on pfizer said
it's time
now the bite administration could do
something else that would really help us
all move forward speed the approval of
the vaccine for the five to 11 year olds
it's time for that it's time it's time
it's just time for that we pretended
that you had freedom for a while but now
it's time the the jig is up okay
and we need to follow the science which
is why i a politician in pressuring
scientists to speed up the approval of
the experimental drug for children even
though children face very very low risk
from coronavirus because of the science
and because anyway forget the science
the jig is up just do it carrot and
stick this is what these people think of
you they don't think that you are a
person
to be persuaded they think you are an
animal to be bribed and goaded and
prodded that's it's not just de blasio
who thinks that it's fauci it's biden
it's the entire liberal establishment
and unfortunately
they've got the power so very often it
works whether we like it or not
if you want to protect yourself
from these sorts of things i would
strongly recommend you check out ring we
got some holidays coming up we got labor
day coming up looking past that columbus
day thanksgiving even not too far into
the future
people might be coming to your house and
you're probably going to want to know
who's at the door when they come a knock
and that's why i would strongly
recommend ring
alarm go to ring.com knowles right now
ring will allow you to see and speak to
whoever is on your doorstep whether that
person is the delivery guy or the
milkman or the burglar or maybe it's
your in-laws coming in for the holidays
and maybe you're going to react
differently depending on who is at that
door okay i'm not saying how you're
going to react i'm just saying maybe
it's good to know that sort of stuff
whether you're in your house whether
you're at the office whether you are on
a beach on the other side of the world
protect your home with ring alarm easy
to install you can keep an eye on every
inch of your house with their terrific
equipment protect your home anytime
anywhere ringalarm ring.com knowles you
get a special offer on a ring alarm
security kit today build a system that's
right for your home have it up and
running in minutes that's ring.com
knowlesring.com
knowles
we are seeing
a national disintegration here
it's well beyond afghanistan okay i
think this is one of the arguments for
the people who said why are we still in
afghanistan one of the arguments really
had nothing to do with afghanistan it
had everything to do with the home front
we no longer have faith in our elections
neither the republicans nor the
democrats don't forget sure trump right
now is still saying and a lot of trump
supporters are saying that the election
in 2020 was rigged you're not i think
you're not allowed to say that anymore
on social media which kind of shows you
some of the problem but democrats have
been saying that 2016 was rigged from
the beginning including hillary clinton
including the vanquished candidate
we've had
increasingly
little little faith in our election i
suppose decreasing faith in our
elections over the past
several cycles
we
no longer trust our other established
institutions beyond the elections
we
just saw leftist militants burn city
after city after city last year
we
have lost our rights
to go to work in many places our rights
to go to church in many places
are right to go to the restaurant
in in many places increasingly so now
we're seeing
less and less faith in our fellow
citizens no one trusts that joe biden is
even awake at this point
so no one trusts that we have a properly
functioning president within the
constitutional order even democrats
don't trust that
they believe that the kind of
bureaucracy and establishment is running
the show
which it which it is obviously
no one believes that joe biden is is
capable at this point of sitting in the
oval office and making sophisticated
grand strategic decisions about the
country
even if you if this were him making that
it would it would actually prove the
point all the more looking at what's
happened in afghanistan looking at
what's happened on the economy looking
at what's happened all over the place on
coronavirus for that matter
the new york times comes out with a
piece
they say how the taliban turned social
media
into a tool for control
see
taliban obviously
obviously very bad
afghanistan very very bad place
no one's disputing that
but they don't seem to be they can see
what's going on overseas they can't see
what's going on in our own country so in
the 1990s the taliban ban the internet
now they use it to threaten and cajole
the afghan people in a sign of how they
might use technology to build power
yeah it's just the taliban doing that
right right no one else is using social
media as a tool for control social media
the big tech companies weren't actually
just built as a tool for control as a
tool of surveillance capitalism and
behavior modification that's not
actually their entire razon detroit
right oh wait it is
right it is
the the regime in afghanistan is now
using social media to incentivize people
to do the things they want and to punish
them for doing the things they don't
want we would never have that in america
right
we would never have such control and
behavior modification through social
media that big tech oligarchs and the
establishment would censor the duly
elected sitting president right we would
never have that here
good grief man before you accuse me take
a look at yourself
before you accuse me take a look at
yourself this there was a tweet going
around uh from regarding the taliban and
it said now after many years afghanistan
has been liberated from a regime that
forces people to wear facial coverings
destroys statues and mutilates the
genitals of children
oh wait a second uh-oh
who is that describing
i'm not i'm not drawing an equivalence
here between
the liberal regime and the taliban but i
am showing you that there are some
commonalities here
in that statecraft in the way that
political people use coercion to shape a
country in the way that the regimes look
at their various constituents at their
various people
and that's a problem
because i'm i'm not saying that america
is like afghanistan that we're that
we're the same sort of place it's no
better here than it is there i'm not
saying that at all
but i am saying that we're on a bad
trajectory okay and we're going to need
to turn things around and i think men if
if we had a thriving country a
flourishing country where things were
stable and people were free
i suspect there would be little
objection
to going to afghanistan or anywhere else
and spreading the american vision of
society and exerting our influence but
the problem is we can barely keep things
together here right now
so you got to build up that country a
little bit
we can't even bring our guys back from
afghanistan we can't even summon the
political will to do that joe biden
admitted this just yesterday he was
supposed to give a press conference he
was conspicuously late again
wonder why i wonder what's going on
wonder how often joe is lucid during the
day but he shows up finally
and he gives his update on the debacle
in afghanistan
before i update you on the
meeting that i had
the leaders of the g7
earlier today i want to say a word about
the progress we're making
on the build back better agenda here at
home
i just got off the telephone
with the leaders in the house
today the house representative's taken
significant step toward making historic
investment that's going to transform
america
cut taxes for working families and
position the american economy
for long-term long-term
growth excuse me
the country that we have been occupying
for 20 years
has now collapsed within a matter of
days
the taliban has stolen all of our
military equipment taken all of our
bases they're now holding americans
hostage behind enemy lines the united
states is already signaling that they
will leave those americans behind
we're all waiting on an update because
we haven't really heard very much from
joe biden on this
and and you're going to open the press
conference talking about
building back better
here you're going to talk about possible
tax cuts
i'm sure i'm sure that for the americans
stuck behind enemy lines
cowering in
huts as the taliban go door to door
knock knock knock where are the
westerners so we can execute you i'm
sure it's going to be a great comfort
and consolation that they know that joe
biden is maybe going to reduce the cost
of community college we're going to
build back better pre-k has never been
so cheap and working families will have
a that's what we all want to hear about
right
right no no of course not now the reason
he's opening his press conference this
way is he's got nothing on afghanistan
he's got nothing he can't there is not
one single thing
that he has done in afghanistan that he
can point to and say this was anything
less than a disaster
and so
he's got to talk about his plans for
lowering the cost of a gender studies
degree or whatever
but he's got nothing on afghanistan so
then he goes out
he talks about this stupid budget thing
and then
he says oh yeah by the way in
afghanistan we're uh we've we were told
by the taliban that we can't get an
extension we're completely giving in to
their demands uh we're probably gonna
he's the implication is we're probably
gonna leave americans behind enemy lines
okay bye and then he turns around and he
leaves and he walks out
build back better turn turn your back
better
turn the president's back better on
reporters
from whom he will not answer a single
question because he can't because
there's no political win there jensaki
was not so lucky
the spokesman at the white house had to
go out her job is to talk to reporters
and she was pushed on this hold on i
thought there were thousands of
americans behind enemy lines they can't
get to the airport you're refusing to
send in
the force is necessary to get them out
so are you saying that we're going to
leave americans in afghanistan
the answer is yes
say after the withdrawal it's done
you know it's declared it's done
everyone's out
if one u.s citizen was suddenly
discovered you know saying hey i really
want to get out and i'm stuck who knows
where somewhere in afghanistan or in
kabul you've got any problem would this
trigger a
diplomatic military
or hands-on deck type thing to get that
person out whatever the date
our commitment continues to be to us
citizens if they want to leave we will
help get them out
of the day
again we expect there could be some uh
but i i don't i'm not going to get into
it further
well she she tried to use this mealy
math language and it just didn't work
she said look we want
to get them out okay we hope we want to
and if they want to get out we'll try to
help them get out but
it's like so what do you expect to leave
people there and she says yes we do
but i don't want to get into it i bet
you don't want to get into it
i bet you don't
so you're cracking down on our liberties
at home you're cracking down on our
rights our tradition our way of life
upending that entirely you can see
whether people wearing the uh secular
kefia there in the press briefing room
masking up there
not even not allowed to go out
increasingly now not allowed to go to
restaurants not allowed to go to church
not allowed to go to work
so you're going to lock us down here and
then you're going to leave us behind
overseas
that's that is what this liberal regime
is telling you
oh oh and i'm sorry there's one third
thing that i forgot we're going to ship
all the afghani people over here that's
what we're going to do and we're being
told that they're being properly vetted
but we've got proof now coming out
from the united kingdom that these
people are not being vetted they can't
be there's too many
a complete dereliction
of duty now if you want someone who
won't derelict as duty to work for your
company i would strongly recommend you
check out zip recruiter i was just in
france a few weeks ago i was over there
i was there for a wedding and i'm
walking around france
and i noticed something there's only
about one waiter at every restaurant
and it's not just because the french are
known for a little leisurely take on on
labor
no it's because they can't get workers
if you go to restaurants in america you
go to stores in america right now you
can't get workers you i mean you
probably know this with your own company
people
have not been working all that much
usually because of lockdowns and
mandates over the past year now
businesses are reopening it's very hard
to find really good talent well if you
want to find good talent go to
ziprecruiter you post your job on
ziprecruiter ziprecruiter sends that out
to a hundred of the top job sites
millions of possible applicants actively
goes out and invites people to apply
finds you the best person time is money
when it comes to hiring hiring the most
important investment you're going to
make right now try zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com knowles that's
ziprecruiter.com canadawlis go to
zipcrutter.comrecruiter the smartest way
to hire with everything going on from
the afghanistan debacle to vaccine
mandates i'm not sure there's a better
place to talk about it all been
backstage join us tomorrow thursday
august 26th at 7 pm eastern 6 pm central
on dailywire.com and on our daily wire
youtube channel don't miss it also today
is your last chance to submit your song
to be the new sweet baby game anthem for
matt walsh's sweet baby gang go to
dailywire.com
sbg submissions end tonight at midnight
go check it out also we've got a great
exciting announcement to share today
deadline hollywood just released the
details in an exclusive photo of the
daily wires first original movie it's
called shut in it's directed by dj
caruso executive produced by daily wires
co-founders
production on the thriller wrapped this
weekend it will be available to daily
wire members beginning in january 2022
this film is centered around a young
single mother who is barricaded inside a
pantry by her violent ex-boyfriend while
using nothing but her voice to guide her
two small children to escape escalating
danger it's an intense suspenseful
thriller delivers riveting action
without missing a beat the trailer for
shut-in will be out soon we know our
members are going to love this film we
entered the entertainment space in order
to send hollywood a message that you no
longer have a monopoly in the film
industry the release of shut-in is just
the next step in proving it we'll be
right back with a lot more
we're getting a report out of the united
kingdom
that the supreme vetting of all of our
afghan allies uh we know we know exactly
who's coming in to the west from this
war-torn country which is extremely
violent which has had
terrible terrorism problems we know
everyone is coming in even though we're
airlifting tens of thousands of people
at a time we know exactly who's coming
in except maybe we don't
a person just entered the united kingdom
from afghanistan who had been on the
no-fly list
now this person
was later not deemed by the uk to be a
person of interest in whatever terrorism
investigation they're undertaking
but it just shows you the problem
the point of the no-fly list maybe you
support the no-fly list maybe you don't
but the the premise of the no-fly list
at least
is that people
who are considered a threat are not
permitted onto airplanes they're not
permitted
in
it's good news i guess that this person
was not considered to be a dangerous
enough threat to keep out of the country
but
how did that person get on the plane in
the first place because obviously the
afghan people who are now being flown
into
this country and others by the tens and
hundreds of thousands
can't be properly vetted it's not
possible
we're already going to leave americans
in afghanistan americans in afghanistan
there's no way that you can do a proper
vetting to get everybody out
joe biden refuses to force the taliban
to extend the deadline to get out
so
we're just trying to try to race against
the clock here
we are going to take into just this
country
possibly a hundred thousand afghan
refugees
something tells me they're not all going
to be properly vetted
now many of them were allies of ours
they helped us out when we were
afghanistan
that's great
thrilled i appreciate they're supporting
us
do we think that
not one
bad guy is going to make it in there
do we think that every single person
there is going to be just thrilled to
join in a madisonian democracy here
they're all going to
just
salute the flag and eat apple pie and
and sing the national anthem well
frankly most americans these days don't
sing the national anthem so never mind
about that
do we really think there's no problem
here because the people the liberal
imperialists
on the left and the right are telling us
that if we in any way raise any
questions about taking in any fewer than
hundreds of thousands of afghan
migrants
that that is to terrible evil immoral
un-american
is that is that the case can the united
states
handle that kind of stuff right now i'm
not even talking about the afghan
migrants in particular
i'm just talking about the open borders
taking in the whole world taking in
millions of people a year
are we really in a good position to
handle that because as far as i can tell
our national policy has been completely
bungled we've lost our way of life
we're losing our national identity and
cohesion we i don't even know what the
migrants will be assimilated into at
this point what is amer what do we stand
for what are our standards
doesn't seem like a great idea
meanwhile back overseas we we've now
heard from the pentagon they've admitted
that the taliban has stolen all our
stuff they've got all of it but
we we actually don't know how much
they've got we don't know we don't know
the stuff that the afghan army had
that the taliban now took and in case
you were wondering no we have no policy
solution to fix it is there any uh
effort to tally up the number of u.s
weapons and equipment that are now under
taliban control and is there any program
to mitigate this problem through
destruction or confiscating them back
taking them back yeah mike i mean we
talked about this uh before i don't have
an exact inventory of what
uh equipment the
that the afghans had at their disposal
that that now uh might be at risk
obviously uh we don't want to see any
um
any weapons or systems uh that uh to
fall into hands
uh
uh of people that that uh
that would use them in such a way to
that that to uh to harm our interests or
those of our uh our partners and allies
i mean uh we have a vested interest
obviously in in not wanting that to
happen um but i don't have any policy
solutions for you today
uh about uh how we would uh or could
address that going forward this this is
embarrassing to watch this is like when
you're in a meeting at your office
and there's there's the flunky guy
there's the flunky guy who you know
maybe he's a good talker or something
but he gets called out he says okay so
have you done this thing are you doing
this thing
what's what have you what are you doing
what have you what have you brought to
the company here and he says well
uh yeah no i mean look obviously yeah
look we want to do stuff for our yeah
for our partners and we want and synergy
you know and but no we don't i don't
so what's your solution then johnny well
no we i don't have so i'm not gonna we
don't exactly have solutions
um but i think it's very important look
we yeah and i don't know i don't have
like numbers okay or um
facts or data or any but i yeah i just
think but it's important we want to have
we want to have that we want to do
better and we're going to do better
right guys
right
that's
that's great
i'm glad you want that
but we need
results
we need and we're not getting results
from our national leaders we're not
getting results
on the covid lockdowns not at all we're
getting quite the opposite of that right
we're not getting results overseas
we're not getting results
anywhere
nowhere none of the we're not getting
results on immigration we're not getting
results on the economy we're not getting
results on inflation we're not getting
results
on anything
so president trump
is deciding to go on the attack this is
probably the strongest evidence yet
that donald trump plans to run for
president again against
joe biden if he's even still in office
and we wonder if that is even possible
but trump just released this early on
2021
a campaign ad
just summing up everything that we've
been seeing for the past few months
america is back the highest inflation
rate in the
uk of covet infections we amplify our
power we summon the new strength this is
a recruitment should we be embarrassed
diplomacy is bad now the taliban are
back kabul is not in an imminent threat
environment the likelihood there's going
to be
the taliban overrunning everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely they own the whole country now
the taliban taliban are now in complete
control of afghanistan
how did president biden get this so
wrong first of all the mission hasn't
failed
yet if this isn't failure
what does failure look like exactly
right
you destroyed not afghanistan
i don't care
if you think i'm satan reincarnated
do i bear responsibility zero
responsibility china is ready for
friendly relations with the taliban
they're just chanting death to america
call yourself a president
[Music]
devastating devastating and you know i
do love that that voiceover that you
hear there from some protesters you call
yourself a president you should be
ashamed but but other than that
everything else was just
news reports everything else was just
joe biden's own words or those of his
spokesmen
the the only editorial part where one or
two lines there from you're you know
you're a bad president or whatever the
rest
it was him indicting himself
and i don't even just mean to blame
biden biden has no idea what's going on
it's the whole liberal establishment
indicting itself
that that ad is more powerful than just
about any ad i've ever seen in politics
morning in america you know as sort of
ronald reagan touting all of his
accomplishments this was like the
flip side of that this is what happens
when everything goes
wrong
now
you're not allowed to say make america
great again i mean guess this gets to
the heart of our problem you're not
allowed to root for america you know we
don't even know what america is if you
if you say you want to make america
great again if you salute the flag if
you put your hand over your heart when
you say the pledge
you are according to the left engaging
in white nationalism because america's
an evil rotten racist bigoted terrible
white supremacist plays
just take a listen to this voicemail
this voicemail was left on the the phone
of carter nordman he's a representative
state rep in iowa
this was a woman who who called him
because he supported a bill that would
have schools say the pledge of
allegiance in the morning just like we
all did when we were kids just like has
been true for a lot of american history
she she got triggered
yes this message is for carter nordman
my understanding that you are the iowa
state representative who
included language that requires all iowa
schools to lead the pledge of allegiance
once a day in grades 1 through 12.
when did we start teaching white
nationalism in schools because that's
exactly what the [ __ ] you're doing sir
and you have absolutely no right to
require something like that
our children aren't proud to be american
maybe the white suburban kids out in
adel are proud to be american because
their rights are afforded to them every
day and they don't have to fight for
them but for the rest of us
who are
women
uh
the poor the elderly uh the minorities
we're not so proud what are we proud of
we're proud of our racist history we're
proud of our racist roots
is that what we're proud of we're proud
of the fact that not all citizens in the
united states are afforded the same
rights and the same privileges as the
blond-haired blue-eyed ones
so
first of all that woman is the voice of
a generation before we make fun of her
before we talk about how kooky and crazy
she is she is espousing what is now the
mainstream point of view that if you say
anything nice about america or its
founding you are a white supremacist
america is an evil place and we need to
undo the founding of the country and
refound the country to to take away that
that racist evil terrible root that's
rotten to the core
the second part that's funny about this
is that this woman is almost certainly
white right because you hear her say she
goes the
maybe it's fine to salute the flag if
you're one of those white
women in the suburbs but for the rest of
us who are
and then you hear there's a little pause
and so if if she's contrasting the white
people with someone else with herself
she would if she weren't white she'd
probably say with who are hispanic
and blah blah or who are black and who
are but she doesn't do that she pauses
she goes yeah maybe the white people in
the suburbs will do that but not the
rest of us who are
women well hold on what women is not the
opposite of white or poor first she's
she's not poor that woman is not she
does not talk like a poor person she
talks like a
rich entitled white liberal sushi
i can hear it i don't i'm just i don't
want to rush to conclusions but
you can hear these things
we we're oppressed
what would we be proud of in our country
and that's the question because after
decades now of teaching people that
there's nothing to enjoy about the
country nothing to be grateful for
nothing of value here uh that that's
what people believe that that
we we have nothing to share to people
abroad which is why now we've got to
pull everyone in from outside
but
the country itself is rotten so we need
to bring in as many other people who are
not western who are not american
to help improve the country
and we need to disrespect our laws as
best we can because our laws were
founded by evil racist white supremacist
people
there is a logic
to their madness it's it's a it's
illogic i mean it's a perverse logic
but there is a kind of coherence in its
perversity
there is some good news for the american
nation rare good news that we get these
days especially rare good news from the
court
the supreme court has you're probably
not hearing about the story by the way
it's not getting a lot of play the
supreme court has just ruled
that the biden administration's attempt
to end the remain in mexico immigration
policy
is is not permitted
under the law of the land and so
the supreme court has refused to block a
lower court ruling that will require the
government to reinstate the trump arrow
policy the remaining mexico policy was a
brilliant policy and it's obviously
right and just the policy is this
we're told that we've got a zillion
asylum seekers coming into america
they're not economic migrants they're
not people who just want to flat our
laws and come in and make a buck
they are
fleeing political persecution they'll be
killed if they remain in guatemala or
honduras or el salvador
and so that's why we've got to let them
into america it's a matter of life or
death if they don't get out of their
nation of origin
and so the trump administration said
okay fine
if if people need to come into america
to flee death
the political persecution then then
we'll do that
but
if those people make it to another
country first
where they'll be perfectly safe
then they've got to stay there
and the reason for this policy is that
of course these guys are coming from el
salvador guatemala nicaragua wherever
have to go through mexico
so if they were really just fleeing
political persecution they would just
stay in mexico they'd stay in the first
place they could outside of their own
country but they're not they're economic
migrants who want to come here because
our economy is better for how long i
don't know but our economy is
theoretically better
and they they think they're gonna have a
better life here and they probably would
so joe biden comes in and he says no
forget about that we can't we can't have
that policy because that's gonna
discourage people from illegally coming
into our country and that's going to
hurt us down the road because we're not
going to be able to just bring in voters
illegally
so what the supreme court did is they
actually uh watched the left get hoisted
on its own petard
the supreme court when trump tried to
overturn barack obama's unconstitutional
daca program
the program that gave executive amnesty
to
illegal aliens under roughly the age of
40.
even though we pretend that they're
dreamers who are like six years old but
they're actually much older than that
uh
the court said no you can't do that you
can't you're actually not permitted to
do that you can't have that kind of
capricious policy change left and right
because then you won't you won't be able
to have a stable country so you've got
to give a compelling reason well they
use that same logic here to
stop the biden administration from
reversing the remaining mexico policy
great stuff speaking of banning stuff
the founder of only fans only fans is
that it's like a social media website
for porn
you you can go on to only fans and
produce your own pornography pictures of
yourself and stuff like that i was
considering starting my own you know
just to make a little extra buck look
i've got a family now okay i've got to
pay some bills and so you can do that if
you're a content creator and then people
can subscribe to your porn and they'll
get like special porn you know even i
know it's not exactly difficult to find
naked ladies on the internet and you
don't have to spend a lot of money to do
it but there is a service now where you
can spend money and feel like you've got
a special relationship with a
pornographer so
only fans announced a week or two ago
that they're going to ban porn from
their website which means their website
is basically gonna have to shut down
there's no they they are a pornography
website so if they ban porn i'm not sure
exactly who's gonna be using their
website
but they did it and they the founder has
just explained why
it's because the banks the big banks
we're pressuring them to because the
banks don't want to be involved in this
cd business they don't want to be
funding some pimp whose name is tim
stokley he's the ceo of only fans they
don't want to be
seen as encouraging 18 year old girls
who want to make a quick buck who aren't
thinking clearly to go turn themselves
into porn stars and they don't want to
encourage this
sick addiction among young men so they
say look you guys if you if you want to
keep doing business with us then you you
gotta get all the porn out of there i
think this is great
okay there's uh unfortunately there's a
coded to this story which we'll get to
in a second but at least the first
announcement i think this is great i
know that there are a lot of
conservatives out there who are gonna
say hold on michael what you think the
banks should be able to exert influence
these are the same banks that are that
are sometimes going after conservatives
these are the same banks who are
sometimes wielding power
to ostracize conservatives from society
so you can't celebrate when they're
wielding power to ostracize
pornographers
yes i can yes i can and it's this kind
of illogic that has really
put the right in a bad position over the
past couple of decades
politics is about more than just form
it's also about substance
the fact that banks are doing anything
is one aspect of the of the political
question
but what the banks are doing is the
other aspect
like for instance
when when leftists say you know michael
if
if we
tell communists that they can't
indoctrinate our third graders in the
classroom if we conservatives were to do
that and kick communism out of the
classroom why that would make us know
better than the left which is trying to
kick american patriotism out of the
classroom
no no it would make us very different
from the left because communism and
patriotism are not the same thing
our first amendment rights and
pornography are not the same thing i
know that people are confused about this
today but for the vast majority of
american history it was never
understood that pornography is protected
by the obscenity is protected by the
first amendment but michael the banks
are going after guns so now you're fine
with them going after pornographers yes
because guns and pornography are
different and one is a civil right and
one is not and one is
generally illegal and even though now we
don't quite understand that but yes
those those are different things
this guy is a pimp this even dresses
like a pimp tim stokley now
unfortunately the bad news we just got
an hour ago is that the
the
only fans has reversed course
they've secured funding they've
pressured the banks whatever
so now they're going to keep pouring out
there
this is bad stuff
conservatives used to be able
to
recognize that there's a difference
between good and bad and right and wrong
i mean basically the people making the
argument that we need to be really
worried that a bank suggest pressured
only fans to get rid of its porn even
though it didn't really work
they're the ones who are making the same
argument the drag queen's story hour is
a blessing of liberty like david
frenchman because they say well who's to
who's to say what's good and bad if if
we to get rid of drag queen story hour
why the left might get rid of church on
sunday which they're already trying to
do by the way no we actually we can know
we can know the difference between these
things
unfortunately a lot of work to do
to re to rebuild our society
a lot of work to forget rebuilding
afghanistan a lot of work to do to
rebuild our society
even on the right for us to make sense
of these things
much more to say we'll have to hold it
for tomorrow i'm michael moses michael
nola shall see you then
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show